benjamin déjà démarré par vous les savez
qui c'est les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui puisque vous en avais pris
par la grainerie mais alors souri hier
quelques choses soient bien claires il
ya il ya eu un début de séquence qui
était le suivant et c'est rené est un
personnage haut en couleurs jeudi il est
extrêmement drôle je respecte beaucoup
il est athée pmp on est une famille et
c'est vrai que c'est remet ce changement
ce bad moi je suis un pétomane j'ai
divorcé de 17 fois j'en prends plein la
gueule
je comprends très bien que rené pas ce
recul met sur hier soir précisément
l'enchaînement étaient les suivants et
cyril et moi on est très complices et sa
garde et pas parce que on veut se moquer
d'eux de rené sait qu il enchaîné
le stif et le dr tartarin rcd moi c'est
moi quand ça commence comme ça avec
cyril d'enseignants en direct oui on est
en direct
eh ben je plonge c'est là contre rené
c'est pas du tout autre euro n'est
effectivement ses prix et comme on est
des saluts et les téléspectateurs l'ont
pris et c'est débile sauber nous et
honnêtement c'est pas du tout contre
rené et honnêtement quand je hais la
séquence après albert après c'est vrai
qu'on est on remet des pièces genre mais
des pièces on va les faire ce qu'on est
parce qu'on est des sales gosses et que
moi je me marre et qu'effectivement plus
je vois rhône est énervé et puis je
rigole parce que c'est parce que je suis
comme ça à l'accepter et c'était pas du
tout on peut s'était même pas sur le
propos de relais parce que qu'ils aiment
ou non le professeur août je vous dis
franchement comme il irait vite je m'en
bats les couilles mais c'est pas le
propos le propos est l enchaînement de
demont quitté très drôle le stif en plus
avec ce week end le stif qui permit de
27 fois le sol voilà après sa propension
je comprends que corner tête était vexé
après tu fais un tweet août une trêve
d'abrutis que ça ou je ne réponds pas
exprès et derrière je te jure que c'est
vrai les conséquences de ça c'est que
moi j'en prends plein la gueule n'est
pas ta gueule on menace ne tuer ma
famille denis dessus des enfants de
déterrer ma merde
même ma grand mère il est nommé après
jeudi à temps qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce
que j'ai fait moi parce que j'ai ri
parce que j'ai ri on va menacer de mort
et là je suis pas d'accord et là je te
lis droit dans les yeux là je suis pas
d'accord parce qu'effectivement avec ce
tweet tu tenais pas rendu compte tu
déclenché le feu nucléaire
et moi je suis pas ici pour me faire
insulter je vois ici pour faire menacer
de mort et je suis pas ici pour me faire
insulter pendant des années et je
regrette sincèrement du fond du coeur si
j'étais blessé parce que c'est pas du
tout toi je voulais blesser
en revanche je regrette sincèrement du
fond du coeur les conséquences de ce qui
s'est passé sur les réseaux que j'ai
quitté parce que l'on pouvait plus de
deux mois quand j'aime et d'enfants qui
fond en larmes et qui paraît je suis
comme toi je pète un plomb est
effectivement tu n'es pas responsable
moi non plus mais faut pas que tu peux
faut pas prendre cette émission
quelle n'est pas on est une famille on
est là pour déconner et ça ne peut pas
ça ne doit pas aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle qui plus est avec tout ce qui
s'est passé on peut pas se faire
insulter se ferment et maçonnerie est ce
que c'est le droit qu'on a droit
c'est une émission léger est loin de là
je ne peux pas faire ça et c'est pas de
toi après je comprends trend sont
énervés et ce que je sais mais je
comprends mais mille fois mille fois
mais si j'avais dû m'énerver à chaque
fois qu'on s'est moqué de moi de mes ex
femme de ma famille de du fait que j'ai
des petits yeux que je pète etc mais
j'aurai alors alors j'aurais juste un
petit bémol à tuer c'est que prenait
grenelle à 73 ans bien sûr j'ai
évidemment voilà c'est pas pareil rhône
et c'est vrai qu'il a 73 ans oui et on a
tendance à l'oublier parce qu'on redis
j'ai tellement aux jeunes on déconne
tellement avec toi on déconne pas
retenir les leçons on vas tu viens me
voir en l'ours on déconne tous les deux
comme des fous et on a tendance à
oublier bien sûr eux j'aimerais un rené
il a 73 ans savent alors il les fait pas
c'est vrai que il est c'est une énorme
rigolade
c'est vrai que c'est notre pote on
oublie qu'on a une différence d'âge
parce que c'est tellement d'autres potes
que va qu'on a oublié pourrait sortir
avec lui tout le temps et rigoler a vécu
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on admet
mal